να βάλετε και τα υπόλιπάμελε της οικογένεια σας σε αυτούς στοτ δεν μπροσπάθεις δεν μπορώ
να πό ότι ε προσπάθησα όλοι βοήθούν με τον τόπον τους η νύθυμου τουικό αλλά
είναι στο νεριθθόσταδο είναι στον κλαδολευκωσίας και κάμνουν πολύ καλή δουλια ο κλάδος λευωσίας γενικά
σγουρ μεένα παντότε με στιωρίζουν σε ότι κάνω κδηλόσεις όλα τα παιδιά για να στασία
έκανε την τεράστια κατί πολύ σημαντικό με τη φωνή νομίζω που ήταν κάτι που πραγματικά
έλειπε καιέτσι δημιουργήθηκε γιατί πάρα πολύ σοβαό και που βοήθα πάρα πολλά παιδιά ο καθένας
κάνει αυτά που το που τον εδιαφέρουν προσωπηηκά πιστεύου αλλά πάντοτεσίγουρα στηρίζουν το μακάλιο νοστοκομείο
επίσης το στηρίζουν που είναιπου το θυρίζω και εγώ και αντότε τα παιδιά βοηθού επομένως
θεωρείται επιδικάνατε αναφορά ότι η αναστασία αδιοικήθηκε κάπου η κάποιοι δεν βρέθηκε σε κάποια έις
επειδή να ηκόρη του τάσου και η αδελφή τουν ικόλα τώρα δεν ξεωραν είναι επειδή
ήταν οη κόρη του τά σου γιαδελφή τουνικό όλα αλλά έχει σίγουρα έχει τα προσόντα
για να προσφέρει αν δε δυστυχώς δεδεμε την τελευταία στελευταίον κι εγώ δεν έγινε κάτι
αλλά νομίζω ότι ίδια είναιευχαριστημένη με αυτά που έχει με αυτά που ασχολείται κα δεν
πρέπει επάντοτε να έχεις μια θέση